now there's a serious issue that we want
to bring to your attention imagine
losing your hearing without warning or
even explanation it is commonly known as
sudden deafness there are tens of
thousands of Americans who struggle with
the condition well now the makers of a
brand new experimental drug say it might
give them a chance to actually get their
hearing back our national correspondent
jerika Duncan went to New Jersey to meet
a man who claims for him the drug may
have already done just that
you're going to get some information on
the fellow on the right Chris sopuch has
taught at Oakcrest High School in New
Jersey for 25 years does it change or
does it say the same but in 2017 at the
age of 48 soapuch was nearly forced to
walk away from his life's work I woke up
January 5th to realize I could not hear
properly out of my left ear just like
that just like that how did you know
that something was seriously wrong when
I first awoke that morning the sound
that I heard was robotic because I was
still hearing sounds and it was like a
screeching sound like I knew something
was majorly wrong he was diagnosed with
sudden hearing loss doctors were telling
you they said there's nothing we can do
there's no way to fix that steroids
didn't work and doctors couldn't
guarantee that hearing aids would help
his frustration captured in these photos
I was just trying to get by from day to
day yeah you don't look happy I was not
happy at all but things changed when he
discovered the biotech company frequency
Therapeutics online it advertised a
clinical trial for an early stage drug
to treat sudden hearing loss this is for
people who were born with healthy
hearing and over time because of noise
pollution that they're hearing you know
really declines the company's co-founder
and CEO David lucino says the treatment
is given as a single shot inside a
person's ear five minutes in the ENT
office and then they'll give you a few
minutes just to make sure you're
recovered and feeling good and then
you're on your way he says the injection
called FX 322 can help to restore
hearing it activates so-called sleeping
cells to make up for the ones damage by
things like aging infection or loud
noises soapuch flew to San Antonio for
the trial about 18 months after losing
his hearing a month later while
traveling for a checkup a breakthrough
everything just came back in life like
all of a sudden like a light switch and
the way that it went off it's the way
that it came back it came right back he
obviously had a great Improvement which
I'm going to attribute to the drugs Dr
Steven iliadis treated so much at the
University of Pennsylvania I don't have
a better explanation for things still
just too early to tell while there's
currently nothing on the market to
restore hearing 11 of frequencies
participants had statistically
significant responses to the drug over
the course of four trials but in a
different multi-dose trial last year
participants showed no reliable
Improvement the company stock plummeted
and some investors sued frequency tells
CBS News it cannot comment on the
lawsuits but says the data was
unreliable because of how particip the
pins were screened and not because of
the drug itself there will no doubt be
people skeptical of the data of the
claims what do you say to those people
stand by and watch us you know I mean
the scientific data will tell the story
was unimaginable getting it back and
never sounded better I'm an 84 but I'm
basically back to life the way it was
before for CBS morning's jarika Duncan
Mays Landing New Jersey
so frequency tell CBS News it has
corrected the previous issues in its
latest trial the company plans to
release new data next quarter and get
the drug to Market in the next few years
that's if FX 322 is approved by the FDA
by then